[Musique]
luc madc bonjour je sens qu'aujourd'hui
vous allez menacer avec un couteau oui
mais vous ne risquez rien Patrice parce
que vous savez que maintenant on fait à
table avec des couteaux à Bourron oui
heureusement oui sinon je serais pas
venu sa pour manger les steaks mais
est-ce que vous savez est-ce que c'est
ce qu'on dit que ce sont les asthèques
qui ont qui ont inventé le couteau pas
du tout le fameux couteau asthèque ah
oui couteau asthèque très drôle oh c'est
une que je ne connaissais pas mais je
vais la ressortir non les couteaux à
bourau c'est une jolie histoire et
finalement on croit toujours que c'est
pour les enfants oui et ben pas du tout
ah bon non c'est le cardinal de
Richelieu qui par un it a exigé des
couteliers du roi qu'on fasse des
couteaux à Bourron à table tiens donc et
pourquoi lorsre des repas avec les
officers
l'ÉE ro éta exaspéré de voir que les
officiers se cur les dents avec leur
Coutau de table et c'est alors qu'il a
décidé en s'adressant au coutolier du
roi de faire arrondir tous les couteaux
pour qu'il puisse plus se curer les
d pas aprs type comme ça oui ça ça
devexaspérer c'est formidable ça oui et
voyez on connait le CAN richieu à
travers des quantités de choses
extraordinaires dont évidemment la
résistance aux Anglais au siège de la
rechelle mais il a quand même laissé en
dehors de cette trace dans l'histoire
absolument extraordinaire un it
obligeant les couteliers pour que les
couteaux de table soitent à bout rond à
partir de sa décision c'est quand même
ex il y a l'Académie française et puis
il y a le couteau à Bouron voil c'est
bon pour les élèves voilà si vous avez
un devoir sur Richelieu sachez ça merci
beaucoup jeanl alors n'oubliez pas le
coup de on le doit au cardinal de
richelie et ça vous allez pouvoir
briller entre amis en racontant ça la
prochaine fois que vous venez dîner
merci beaucoup jeanluc merci
[Musique]
Patrice